ouf
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est l'un quand on peut être un gars
comme ça ça m'a tant chez moi ou alors
j'ai vu sur scène c'est nous bah oui
c'est pourquoi pourquoi c'est vous cyril
[Musique]
ça va ça va être quoi c'est comme si de
rien et faire tu n'as rien entendu ça
charmant sourire si l'état merci à mon
pc jeudi soir et oui celle-là je pense
qu'il peut rester un peu plus longtemps
eh oui j'avance il mange des voix l'aï
mérité shabbat et c'est vrai que c'est
que voilà qui fait la chanson rock
énormément j'ai perdu c'est toi c'est
bien mais c'est pas fini sur balles et a
perdu combien je suis enchanté là pour
l'instant sept kilos normal c'est pour
dire des photos de koh lanta est pas là
où vous pensez ciel
coulisses de l'émission
cl vous savez de quoi sont friands les
téléspectateurs français et s'offrir en
quoi sa copine
oui des coulisses des loges c'est ça
quand green challenge serait jamais le
loup est bienvenu dans sa catégorie side
tpp et on commence tout de suite avec
baba qui est très très heureux de
l'ouverture des terrasses
[Applaudissements]
qui fait ça ollo bernard montiel à la
place de benjamin castaldi dans de 6 à 7
prendra-t-il sa place tu es vachement
bien dans le sens d'un donc si ça ça qui
prime
pas mal de gens qui me demandent de
virer castaldi non non non non non vous
êtes sûr bernard donc il fallait dire et
en plus ça coûte cher mais changer le
nom l'adresse commenter le cas pour
continuer avec cyril cas décoiffé
pernikoff en lui mettant des bons dans
sa gueule
le ménage
mais comment ces 62 % et 6 % à 1 ajoute
bon ok après bernard montiel le piquet
de place découvrez bernard montiel le
sex-symbol faire plaisir et puis
nouvelles recrues pour les jeux de
guillaume genton il s'appelle dans une
bosse bien des faiblesses
l'isq il
souci de garderie d'argent' célibattante
mm et ski tout nu mm est ce qu'il est
mesquine quoi alors la preuve chez elle
au petit déjeuner tiens en parlant
guillaume genton il fait qu'on peut
copains que les invités souci
[Musique]
des jours en semaine si j'adore pourquoi
après roland garros et wimbledon cyril a
trouvé un nouveau terrain de jeu pour
jouer au tennis
[Musique]
trois ans après berlin maintient le
piqueur de place bonaventure le
sex-symbol voici bernard montiel le
tabac et cette année on s'en fout on
fait avec damas qui a fait un peu trop
de sport
il a mal à y croire il paraît que c'est
rien bref c'est une épidémie thouet j'ai
fait beaucoup de vélo c'est ça j'ai les
couilles en fout ça va mieux cette
séquence il ya quand même un gars
cagoulés qui passe derrière alors
c'était le fils de selim qu'on en voit
que ça va mieux
de quoi balayer connaître ses rayons la
mévente 50 secondes inside bien
guillaume genton qui a continué à donner
des petits défis figurez vous que ces
défis ou genton qui va bien sûr pas ses
larmes à gauche il est blanc mais j'ai
eu vent de l insee la collection hiver
en fait d'accord et en plus c'est vrai
qu'il a vraiment appeler le vent de la
houle
donc je suis pas collectionneur dans
l'étang du continent c'est quand j'ai un
truc qui te rendes compte d'un truc une
fois décidée par le biais de genton
cyril figurez vous que ces défis on se
sont sortis des frontières de touche pas
à mon poste et même des frontières de
ces huit surtout avec jean meciar
regardez bien le magnéto c'est
incroyable ce qu'a réussi à faire
vous placez à guillaume genton agents
laetitia c'est incroyable mais je peux
vous dire s'il attendait vous n'avez pas
vu vous n'avez pas vu ce qu'ils
s'intéressent à moi vous regardez là ça
fait dix ans qu'on veut laisser sur toi
selon ses mots là parce que vous me
trouvez est ce que ça ne fait même pas
ça comme ça je pense à beaucoup de moi
tu n'as aucun talent vestimentaire
autant pour faire placer les mollahs
c'est un champion voilà
[Musique]
alors mon chien vous aidez moi de la
séparation
vous la gardez vous considérait
effectivement que vous avez à y gagner
une sorte de moule à gâteau des tic
ulaga politique vous savez vous voulez
effectivement aller dans le sens du vent
sur ses news
pour parler comme les jeunes je crois
beaucoup de français en depuis un an à
attendre de faire la malle à c'est à
dire de faire la fête comme les vôtres
en action mais vous en action tu joues
tu sors tu es ce que vous avez joué
propre et théâtre c'est jose les jeux sa
minorité six zones
merci jean bessière et merci solution
[Musique]
tellement bien réparé
il ya aussi l'économie c'est la drogue
sait ce que c'est ce que c'est c'est
quelque chose qui était résumée par un
rappeur tellement de biff générés par le
four là où je suis effaré sais que j'en
mettrais
[Applaudissements]
quand j'essayais de me posera bonjour
oui parce qu'en fait j'ai à parakou est
devenu mon joli conte raconté la paix
des non loin du bord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi
messieurs et la marionnette de guillaume
vous avez vu il le regarde à chaque fois
pour voir il va prendre l'oseille c'est
énorme c'est ce que ça tout ça personne
en personne c'est dit c'est véridique
n'avait plus qu'à le faire changer le
faire chanter sur ses idées et vous aura
dit et je vais prêter une autre baisse
la highway pour ce soir un succès
[Rires]
certain succès en cinq sets en échec à
l'est de la mer si diouf genton
l'artiste on passe maintenant à stevie
c'était bien on savait que vous aviez un
atome crochu pour nicolas pernikoff a
alors dit par la tempe gauche juin
on dit pourtant un crochet en atomes
crochus sait on dire ou bien s'il ya
personne pour me remplacer valoir que
quand même tu apprennes un peu quelques
expressions non mais voilà moi il avait
un crush y avait un creux à ne pas faire
de bruit que la perle et que voit avec
les équipes de lundi quand on sait les
mousses tir martin aura certainement des
verrues et le cas mais coeur avec les
équipes on a remarqué qu'en fait si vie
et ben il n'y avait pas nicolas
pernikoff dans son viseur
c'est vrai si vous tendez une boîte de
mon chéri à stv il apprend bouffer cas
est en train de devenir un sex symbol
nicolas pernikoff est longue et tout
laisser tomber pour nicolas pernikoff
annonce à mon chéri ah ouais mais juste
et 6 me femmes usine sort avec mon chéri
ne sera pas là pour mettre se le mettre
dans la baule
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà
lui
[Musique]
cornu
regardez tu m'as pas rater les autres
[Musique]
alors en ébullition
tous les trois on va quoi s'est fait
tomber les cheveux la ce a suivi et en
coupe on sait pas encore
alors oui bon cyril avant de repartir
vous savez que l'indiquent aime bien
être le poil à gratter du paf
si tu aimes bien foutent un peu le web
sur ce plateau quoi cette scène je me
coûte le dawa puisque c'est vrai que
c'est quoi le roi des ringards
c'est la veste c'est la mère qui veut ça
et cyril donc cette maniaque
chroniqueurs ou une chroniqueuse qui a
été particulièrement faux cul bien
manger du saucisson abandonniez
saucisson sec permet la rosette amsellem
je veux pas trop en parler sur la tête
de ma mère j'ai l'impression d'avoir un
morceau de piquer d'à côté loi à manger
du saucisson en revenir n'ont cessé là
c'est le rose est non mais sinon c'est
pas juste un bridge que je m'éloigne et
si vous voulez elle veut aussi visible
chez bride sept médias or ce reliquaire
ou une chroniqueuse qui a été très faux
cul avec un camarade et l'indic ne peut
pas laisser passer ça alors c'est très
rapide donc on a décortiqué pour vous
l'image tendez bien l'oreille
regardez bien on a tout décrypter c'est
le retour du jeu qui allait partir en
sucette sur la tête de xavi de te dire
oui c'est ça la vie
[Applaudissements]
ça va partir en sucette sur la tête des
top hydratant frontières
[Applaudissements]
c'est plutôt la la la la la c'était le
dernier
ah bah oui attendez ça fout la merde un
peu entre eux tiffany s'est mis là oui
c'est un match un peu le poil à gratter
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]